we know you've been here as crew working
at London from comic-con and the way the
show masters events but you've turned
actress ever you I mean you are going to
be in a very big show sure that I guess
people will have heard on what's it
called Sherlock yeah now what was the
experience like I'm working on that it
was absolutely amazing and I thought
being Supporting Actress that and being
knew that you wouldn't really be
bothered about but everyone was lovely I
got treated as though I'd been there the
entire time and it was digital part the
family sort of thing even though it's
all brief and what was it like working
with Benedict Cumberbatch and Martin
Freeman as world not Martin I'm afraid
no not Martin I'd just been a jet but
Benedict's lovely um he's oh it just it
was just so nice at one point he was
asking if I was warm enough because my
hands were called unfortunately that's
just something i have i have very cold
hands and making faces in between takes
so and a really nice guy now you just
telling me because we were talking
off-camera that an interesting incident
happened the other day after you told
someone that you'd held valid it came
about his hands yes and she got very
excited and grabbed hold of my hand and
yeah she she mentioned she was a medical
professional a little bit scary she
might make away with your hand to keep
it as it keeps saying yeah it may end up
like the doctors hand in a jar let's
hope no no I'm very attached to my hand
thank you very much i can't grow another
one now tell us a little bit about your
character
the left and Miss Mary Sutherland a case
of identity for those that know the
original Sir Arthur Conan Doyle stories
and she works hard and she keeps her own
money she gives her heritance money to
her mother and her stepfather but she
starts to set a feigned as most young
women do she wants some meal
companionship and her stepfather is
worried that you'll lose the money so he
and the original stories takes on a guys
and the new one net said internet dating
lures her into this relationship but she
doesn't know it's him she thinks someone
else she approaches Sherlock to get help
to find out what happened to a lover
because he goes missing and the original
stories he leaves it at the altar and
trying to remember know it
it also have unravels that it was a
stepfather that did this and the
original stories Sherlock Holmes doesn't
tell her he lets her have the illusion
that something happened he's disappeared
and he doesn't want to be cruel and the
new version she knows because he makes
his opinion of her stepfather quite
clear some friends over now how helpful
was it going back to the original source
material I'm actually a fan of Sherlock
Holmes myself I've got the complete
works and the house I've played the
computer games i watched share a lot
before and I got the part so knowing it
is it's vain but with the modern version
because they they change some of the
angles compared to the original and I
don't think it really matters all that
much to know the original story and but
it's not really difficult for everyone I
think has been there at some point where
their hearts being crushed so how is it
the pressure going into such a huge Oh
as Sherlock as your first job I didn't
think I didn't actually realize how big
it was because I just went Oh Sherlock
this is great my family were excited my
friends were excited and then I did the
piece and again that was all good it was
only after information got leaked online
and people started approaching me I was
going oh and as x going on and
information is spread it's got bigger
and and that's when you feel the weight
and I really hope that like i said is
sharp i really hope that they like it
and i do them proud because they are
very protective of it and people say
that
it's a back into like an ownership the
the information that these people can
access and I started I started
researching the fans and seeing the fan
fiction and the art and the jewelry and
all the things that they may can create
about the show is just so large and
fantastic there has been so much kind of
speculation about the the new series and
also lots of press as well of course
trying to get what's going on what's
happening so when we talked to Jeremy
Lovering he I asked about the pressure
having that kind of all that publicity
around he said they'd actually filmed
some fake seems so to kind of put people
off the trial so what do you think about
that and filming the fixings I thinks a
very clever thing and I don't personally
like pot spoilers I don't like to give
things away because I think it ruins
part of the fun the press i think is
good just building up the excitement
which i think is part of the thrill
these days and crime dramas something
that's really quite popular so there's a
lot of competition and and it's quite
good for the the share a lot team to
film the fake things because then people
are going we don't know what's real and
what's not definitely it keeps us all
guessing even longer doesn't it I mean
when you were saying you're a fan of the
show as many many people are I myself as
well and we use speculating and did you
have your own theories about how
Charlotte was going to survive through
that final episode of the last series
and I did but I have to be honest not
for very long me and my mom watched her
and when he jumped off and my mom just
went he's not dead
there thurs I have a theory that I I
spotted and when my mum made me rewatch
the dvds after filming and so I do have
my own theory potential theory as to
what happened the fans have probably
already come up with this there's a van
just a sort of next to the bus stop
that's filled with linen and saw and
that's what it looks like to me I think
that he's probably landed in that and
rolled off and they've put some blood
and whatnot and the cyclist was
definitely paid to crash into Java
conspiracy yeah but the thing is is
Cheryl oak as sometimes or generally
five steps ahead of everyone else so he
knew what was coming so he would have
had time to set things in place and in
fact that he got the paint of that is it
tells Molly that he needs her help so
who better to fake a day yeah would you
like to see Moriarty make it come back
and if that were possible and how do you
think the show will adapt to losing
Moriarty and I did like the character my
mum as a Moriarty fan and she does like
to occasionally see that as she will
burn the heart out of me if I don't make
dinner properly and no so Betsy yeah but
the way I see it once a character is
dead and he did shoot himself in the
head and they're dead he's not a Time
Lord he's not coming back and at least I
don't think that should happen and I
think it should be ok because there's
quite a lot of bad guys in this as
Sherlock Holmes
and bad women in the ad low and so I do
think it will survive because it isn't
just about the bad guy there's a lot of
other characters and Molly Hooper is
original character and they didn't think
she would sort of be as popular as she
is and she ended up staying and again
she's got quite a large following as
well delivery talking to thank you thank
you
you